well we can speak now to dr. Oliver
Johnson the program director for the
Kings Sierra Leone partnership he
returned from Freetown Sierra Leone
just this morning Oliver thank you very
much indeed for being with us you've
returned for a short period and when you
came into the country
what kind of screening did you go
through this morning well the first
thing to say the screening started
before I came into the country even as
they left Freetown Airport there was a
detailed history taken my temperature
was checked three times by a health
worker and then arriving at Heathrow we
had was another temperature check and a
detailed history with a nurse there who
took a picture of everyone who was
coming out of West Africa which is
interesting because exit screening is
something that has been talked about a
lot in Europe today and there's been a
lot of international supervision of
airports in West Africa to make sure
they're up to scratch so I think what we
can say is it's gulia you know robust
intervention there to make sure Britain
remains safe but what we've got to
remember as well is that to stay safe
it's got to be about tackling the
response at the heart of the outbreak in
West Africa we can't just put up walls
what we've got to do is reduce
transmission and stop the outbreak right
back in Sierra Leone and Liberia Guinea
where the cases are being transmitted
from it just in terms of the screening
and you got to Heathrow there was more
screening for you today and what kind of
monitoring do you go through now so it's
different for every patient and so what
they'll or every passenger rather so for
every passenger they'll work out their
level of risk and they'll decide you
know whether they need to be followed up
or whether or not just to give them good
health information and good you know
maybe regular phone calls to take
temperatures this sort of thing so it's
a robust practice that's one we're
seeing across the world at the moment
and it's yeah I think it's very
appropriate and you're confident of that
practice and the protocols that have
been put in place are the right ones
yeah I mean I defer to the specialist of
Public Health England who are the real
experts on this what I really know is
it's Sierra Leone but for me I know I
was impressed tonight there's a medical
expert with what you know about how
Ebola can be contracted you're confident
yeah I mean it seemed very appropriate
to me in terms of the experiences that
you've had in Sierra Leone you've been
out there for two years now so you were
out there at the point at which the
Ebola crisis took hold what has it been
like for you I think when we first heard
that there was a bola in the region what
we expected would was we'd see maybe a
dozen cases or a couple of dozen where
the King's team is based in in Connaught
Hospital in downtown Freetown we serve a
small unit what we've actually
experiences is far beyond what any of us
could have imagined hundreds so I think
we you know from day one we were
starting to get trained MSF was there
the World Health Organization and Kings
brought in infectious diseases
specialists in UK who'd managed a bola
before so we were really doing our best
to get ahead of the game but the country
of the whole you know its health system
wasn't prepared for waters has been a
tsunami of new patients and what we're
seeing at the moment is an exponential
increase that means that every day there
are more new cases than there were the
day before there's a desperate effort at
the moment of which Kings are the
central part to try and set up more beds
so we can isolate patients in from the
community and stop people transmitting
into their homes but at the moment we're
still playing catch-up and I know the
British governments you know the whole
effort of the British Army the Foreign
Office differed in other organisations
is to get that bed capacity up so that
we can turn this outbreak around and
begin to reduce the number of cases what
are conditions like now working in there
and have they changed over the past few
months as the world has woken up to the
threat of Ebola I think the world did
wake up late at one point you know Kings
was one of the only organizations
alongside mid senza frontiere whu-oh who
were there what we're now seeing is a
major response to a lot of funding and a
lot of organizations now flying in more
medical experts more supplies the
challenge really is to find
organisations willing to go on the
frontline a lot of organizations are you
know for doing training and other things
but to really have the clinical
specialists he'll go
shoulder-to-shoulder with Sierra Leonean
colleagues who are fighting this on the
frontline is the challenge and what we
need now is people like that and people
from across the NHS to come forwards so
that we can get hospitals ready
hospitals opened and begin to you know
take the challenge back to this disease
and be on the front foot again and there
are many like you who will say this is
my job this is my duty this is what I
want to do but in the knowledge that you
are putting yourself at risk I've been
overwhelmed by the quality and the sort
of self-sacrifice and confidence of the
people like my team I've got about 10
doctors nurses pharmacists from the NHS
who have taken time out to come as
volunteers to really you know step up
and they are you can minimize the risk
but no organization can never eliminate
it and so absolutely people who are out
there they're aware of the risks but
they're putting themselves in danger not
only because they want to make sure that
we protect our colleagues in in Sierra
Leone and and the patients there but
also to keep britain safe but seeing
what you see and the suffering that you
see day after day after day on the scale
that we're seeing with ebola what impact
does that have
I think for all of us it's it's it's a
horror what we're seeing out there it's
it's the modern-day plague for the whole
city of Freetown which I know the city
is completely changed it's it's a quiet
city now and there's a tension that
everyone feels everyone's afraid and for
doctors and nurses that people are my
team we've had colleagues be medevac
flown out other colleagues seralini and
colleagues who have died and we've been
the ones to treat them every day now
we're seeing whole families young
children aunties uncles grandparents all
come in many of them died and sometimes
just one or two family members left and
desperate pleas from communities who say
look I've got a sick relative at home
can't we you know bring them into
hospital but there simply aren't enough
beds leading to really horrible choices
and so it's so challenging very
challenging time and we're seeing
situations now where children have been
orphaned and they're also being
distanced from their own communities
because of the fear that they might have
contracted or be carrying the virus you
know what we tried to do is to really
demonstrate that the confidence that
survivors should feel by you know when
they leave hugging them helping them
back into their communities to try and
reduce the stigma but the stigmas
everywhere at the stigma is also felt by
our health workers in the hospital
Sierra Leonean colleagues but two
fantastic young nurses there who have
been told by their uncle where they live
you can't come home if you continue to
work in that unit and they've said well
we're committed to this it's we're doing
this for our people in our country so
they now live in the hospital with us
because they can't go home and many of
the British health workers when they
come home they stigma come you know you
can't have you felt that coming home you
know I have had I've got a family and
friends who have welcomed me back but I
know others have felt it hard to pin
said you can't come to this event or you
know you know welcome here or we're
afraid of touching you and I think that
there is a real sense now of fear in the
UK as well about these also
things and from the you know the British
government I think the decision to stop
the direct flights by Gambia bird from
London to Freetown is it it's a
devastating blow to the response and
it's a it's really disappointing that
the government has made that decision we
had urgent medical supplies and urgent
new volunteers who would do for those
flights but I think there's a lot of
fear now amongst in the government and
so sometimes I think sometimes over
reactions okay dr. Oliver Johnson thanks
very much indeed for talking to us and
good luck when you return to Sierra
Leone thank you